what sticking with that story the
national security analysts arish aramesh
joins me now from Houston in Texas thank
you so much for joining us this morning
Irish and can you explain why
president-elect and Donald Trump would
choose Nigel Farage a politician here in
the UK before actually meeting the Prime
Minister here you know Nigel Farage
represents pretty much the same set of
ideals or at least populous sentiment
that mr. Trump either represented or try
to represent or rode the waves to
winning an electoral victory in the
United States both men are staunch
anti-immigration staunchly
anti-immigration both men happened to be
protectionists when it comes down to the
economic views both men happen to be
anti traders both men happen to have
certain isolationist streaks and their
foreign policy and economic views so um
to see that he has reached out and and
by the way let's not forget that nigel
farage hey to the united states and
campaigned for and campaign for mr.
Trump which was sort of odd to see a
foreign you know politician coming here
campaigning an out presidential election
but again there are a lot of
similarities between the two men not to
mention they're both pretty well
see.well fee which is sort of kind of
odds with the populace sentiment now
looking at what's going on in America
there's a backlash I'm over the these
elections protests are still continuing
in cities across the country any sign of
them letting up perhaps not first and
foremost people have an absolute first
right amendment for peaceful assembly
for protests for free speech mr. Trump
won this election fair and square let's
not let's not joke about the legitimacy
of this election when it comes down to
the electoral college winning state by
state mr. Trump one more electoral votes
and he won the election he is now the
president-elect however mrs. Clinton has
won over six hundred and three thousand
more votes so she is ahead in the
popular counter than that it's quite
clear to see that a after such a
divisive camp
after such harsh rhetoric used by both
candidates especially after such
rhetoric used by mr. Trump so many
Clinton supporters are upset and
especially now they feel aggrieved
because they think that their candidate
for whom I voted by the way just to be
very transparent here on TV that you
know she got more votes but yet she lost
the election but to be completely
transparent we have the rules the rules
are at the Electoral College and mr.
Trump won the election according to the
rules whether I like it or we like it or
not so after a couple of days of a shock
Donald Trump is now getting down to
business choosing the people he's going
to be I'm taking to the White House and
with me tell us more about that you know
I like mr. Trump to convince the
American people that he represents all
of us I'd like mr. Trump to convince us
that those rhetoric the rhetoric that
was used in the campaign that could have
been perceived as sexist misogynist
racist so on and so forth was not
exactly the best of mr. Trump I'd like
him to make certain appointments to
prove that unfortunately so far he
hasn't done that one of his key
appointments so far has been mr. Steven
ban and Steve Bannon is someone who was
sort of chased out of the Republican
Party a few years back he belongs to
what we call here the alt right movement
alt right movement is pretty close to
some people who would call even who
would be considered as white nationalist
or white supremacist here in the United
States crazy conspiracy theorist some
people who actually thought that 911 was
an inside job and also that they think
that the government is undertaking a
genocide against white people and not
only that Steve Madden has a very very
mixed bag in terms of e to mix personal
back of no political views and political
sort of reputation so appointing Steven
Bannon a senior adviser to that
president who is you know going to be
pretty much the second most important
person after after the chief of staff in
a white house is a terrifying signal to
the rest of the society and the rest of
the country that has hoped for mr. Trump
ITAT least tried to be a united and a
unifier and not a divider and we also
saw rain spirits that
chairman of the Democrat Republican
National Committee to become a chain or
jeddah chief of staff the White House at
least mr. Priebus has a track record he
does not belong to the fringes of
American politics but I'm very concerned
with Steve banners appointment as as as
a special counsel or senior advisor to
president and the viewers can just look
him up and go on his page and see a lot
of controversial controversial and
racially aggressive comments that mr.
Bannon has uttered in the past several
years a very reason why he was chased
out of his own party the Republican
Party and so that is very concerning but
again this five-minute despite political
differences I'd like to mention a few
names are actually going to be at least
we know who they are I strongly disagree
with for instance General Mike Flynn but
I think he's a patriot met despite our
disagreements over policy I think
Lieutenant General Mike Flynn is going
to be someone who's going to bring it a
lot of experience and a lot of knowledge
with him to the job be it department of
defense if they get him a waiver or a
biet national security adviser or
something along those those lines but
policy differences don't necessarily
frighten us or frighten me what
frightens me is but what frightens me
and really disappoints me is when
president elect Trump appoints chooses
someone so on the fringes of American
society that you know his shoulders with
he rubs shoulders with white
supremacists in America and that is
terrifying okay Irish Irish really good
to talk to you open next few days I'm
sure we'll find out a little bit more
about Donald Trump's administration
thanks so much